[Music]
previously on model lifestyle the next
day we were on our way to the Hou train
that will take me to the airport
[Music]
[Music]
this is my plan right here check it out
[Music]
here
[Music]
Hey so I made it to South Korea this is
my model apartment I'm gonna stay here
for a few months I'm very tired I've
been traveling for over a day so I'm
just gonna rest up a little bit get my
energy back get settled in and a few
days I'm going to show you the model
apartment and South Korea so good night
the seasons coming go like thoughts of
you like a wave returns to the scene in
terms of nature but in a cycle that I
can't lose each painful but in life
- faster
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey good morning it's been actually a
couple of weeks that I've been here in
South Korea so I just wanted to settle
in and find my feet kind of this is the
model apartment this is not a TV show
this is the real model apartment in real
life I've got my own room there's two
beds but I'm just using this one over
here yeah and then you just have the
basic stuff got it deposit and that's it
I'm gonna show you guys the rest of the
apartment as well and actually I'm not
staying alone I'm here with another
South African model max oh he's here
check it out so max arrived just a
little bit later just after me and you
might recognize him show you guys a
little bit closer you recognize him you
might recognize him I'm gonna add it
here this is the Georgia mining campaign
[Music]
[Music]
so let me show you the rest of it oh
wait wait wait he's also a musician he's
a rapper and I'm gonna add his link in
the video description so you can check
out some of his stuff if you liked it
give him a shout he's talented he's got
some really cool stuff I'm willing and
able to make oh babe indicator on the
wood let me say both how much it was a
anything table coming in hot with
alright so let me show you the rest of
the apartment so this is our office this
is where we work we work here I added my
videos he's doing his stuff editing his
music and recording every now and then
and yeah god this is what we need we got
our coffee thing going on here max is
taking a break from coffee yeah I have a
problem I'm a coffee addict I gotta try
to stay away from coffee a little bit
okay so we got a normal cutlery stuff
over here so at least we can make some
food got a fridge that we have to share
but this is it guys a model apartment is
not that special
just one couch then we have the
over here that is the modal apartment
so now I'm gonna show you guys how self
curry looks like let's go whoa all right
it's a little bit dangerous here let's
get off the road whoo all right this is
a little bit better right
so there's around 51 million people in
South Korea and the economy is booming
because of giant companies like Samsung
LG and car companies as well like
Hyundai and Kia and those kind of
companies now apart from that North
Korea and South Korea are actually still
in war well maybe not for long because
Trump is here and he's doing his thing
so let's see what happens in the future
but apart from the war is very very safe
here and very clean the South Korea is
fast becoming one of my most favorite
countries in the world let me go and
show you some more all right
another thing about Korea is that most
of Korea is actually covered with a kind
of forest so beautiful here
[Music]
yes Korea is very very green so even if
you are in the city like I'm in Seoul
right now right so in the city if you
want to find some peace and quiet you
can just go to one of these parks and
just chill a little bit there's a lot of
Heritage Sites as well that you can go
and visit and check out and yeah I don't
have enough time to really go and show
you guys a little bit of this so let's
move on to the next place all right
we're the new place now
South Korea is rich in culture and
history and architecture as well that is
very unique like the palace I'm out here
it is called Bianca coom palace if I'm
pronouncing that wrong and there's some
Koreans that's watching I'm really sorry
I'll add the name of the palace here
just to make sure it's correct
[Music]
feels like I just traveled back in time
[Music]
but some reason that we will be able to
go in but we cannot go and see the
palace
right so I've seen the palace it is
beautiful it is sight and it's not like
something you just come and you just see
it it's like you kind of feel it feeling
yeah and that's different but all right
let's go on let's move on to the next
place all right so right now I am in
Gangnam now Gangnam it sounds familiar
right from the song oppa Gangnam style
it came from here this is called Gangnam
and it is in Seoul South Korea and this
place is famous this street here is
called Green Street now there's a lot of
young people and people who dress up and
kind of come out here just to shop and
just a joke there's a lot of big brands
out here you can see like guests over
there and there's a lot of other stuff
and it's interesting but Korea is also
famous for plastic surgery South Korea
is also the largest center for plastic
surgery in the world yeah it is said
that one out of every three women aged
between 19 and 29 at some sort of
plastic surgery so you can find places
like this all over South Korea so noisy
[Music]
right so I'm in the train station and
I'm waiting for my train back home
and I just have to share this with you
guys because this is one of the first
countries that I've been in apart from
Japan where the subway is just clean it
is so amazing the people are so
respectful and it's just this is
something else and then every now and
then Korea surprises you with these
interesting unique things like this
check it out now this is pretty cool
because this is a statue in the subway
this is so cool it's a cèlle period
terracotta figure and it's mounted on a
horse that is fully equipped with all
the trappings dated from the 5th to 6th
century I mean that's all
[Music]
Hey so I'm just show you guys a little
bit of Korea and whenever we're in new
country that's what we do we do a little
bit of sightseeing and stuff and in the
day we go to castings or jobs but at
nighttime like it is right now we're
just sitting shelling and working that's
our normal day here it's up welcome to
the office don't just go without your
touch down please bro
maybe then a make a bus and go show all
the homies all excited like whoa
have you heard of foreign boy Louise
dope don't trust for that your touchdown
please bro you need in a major bus and
go show me so excited
[Music]